they declined to wear the rainbow and it
drove a reporter nutso
not quite a rhyme but i'll take it
five baseball players on the tampa bay
rays named after ray oro rorya heroia
if only i could say his name
[Laughter]
they opted out of where i know it wasn't
even close they opted out of wearing
pride patches on their uniforms at a
pride night game honoring lb
lgbtq pride month to celebrate gay pride
if i say pride one more time i get my
own float in the parade
with my dancers hans clive and fritz
now the baseball players cited their
religious calm down
they cited their religious beliefs one
of them jason adam telling the tampa bay
times it quote comes down to a
faith-based decision he adds that he
wants gays to know they all are welcome
and loved here hmm welcome and loved
here those sound like fighting words
so leave it to espn which used to cover
sports to weigh in
on the show called around the horn
which is also the instructions i give to
my waxing specialist
this is not just about baseball that
religious exemption bs which is used in
sport and otherwise also allows for
people to be denied health care jobs
apartments
children
prescriptions all sorts of rights and so
we have to stop tiptoeing around it
because we're trying to protect people
who are trying to be bigoted from asking
for them to be exempt from it when the
very people that they are bigoted
against are suffering the consequences
exactly
choosing not to wear a patch is the same
as denying someone an apartment
she squeezed in one more b word before
the segment ended
it's not just about accepting bigotry
within the halls of sport it's about
encouraging people to learn and get
educated so that that changes
so according to espn the players are
bigots
for not wearing the pride patches which
was optional by the way so you better do
it or they're gonna call you a bigot
at espn they're so expecting accepting
of everyone who thinks just like them
but if you're gonna force employees to
wear patches just make sure it's for a
cause that everyone can support
[Laughter]
i
i don't know why
guy i go to you for
not because you love man
because you love baseball
you love baseball and um
you know it's optional why is it right
to compel people to do things isn't that
i mean this is just wrong it's wrong
wrong wrong wrong you're going to burn
in hell
respond
you want to talk about wrong greg yes
i can't help but notice yes that
you all despite my multiple emails on
this
are not wearing my mandatory celebration
pride socks
none of you
not one of you and you all responded in
your own little group text and i know
that and you show your pride at like
the zaddy raven p10 i'll see you there
yes but
in all seriousness i saw this story
i thought immediately about colin
kaepernick right and the kneeling
which was his free speech yes and we
were told that was good and even if it's
offensive too bad he has a right to
speak but
compelling other athletes to wear
something on their body
is what i'm just trying to keep straight
what the rules are that's a good one
um and the other thing is
as a member of the community yes
it doesn't really mean very much to me
if someone is wearing something to make
me feel good but wearing it against
their will it means nothing it means
it's compulsory and it does not help
anyone in my opinion wear it if you want
to wear it that is good if you don't
let's play ball and enjoy the game oh
i'm glad you said enjoy the game yeah
well i'm i'm a baseball fan greg as
we've established because that play ball
thing can go anywhere he makes a really
good point though this is just like the
pronoun stuff it's like
if if if you want to be called something
by pronoun cat
what if
how does it make you feel if you know
it's being forced it's like like that
you know you have to do it or you'll
lose your job yeah it doesn't make any
sense i think it actually could create
more harm because it's creating a false
reality yeah because then everyone
thinks okay everybody really wants to
wear this i'd rather
have knowledge of who does and who
doesn't
and i think a lot of times these people
who push this kind of stuff they i don't
know how but they don't seem to
understand that you know forcing someone
to shut up or forcing someone to say
they agree with you isn't the same as
getting them to understand or accept you
so if that's your ultimate goal then
that's the last thing you should be
doing
you know tyrus
this is i thought this stuff would die
down but why does the nfl have to
participate in everything well this is
nfl baseball because they're all they
all deal with corporations yeah sponsors
because i find it laughable that you
want to attack a player who's basically
saying that while i accept the lifestyle
i just don't want to wear the patch yeah
but yet you will do nothing about the
corporations you work for that will have
they will put gay pride flags up
everywhere and they'll do those things
in places where it's where it's accepted
and we're all working towards
normally inequality but they don't do
they don't do that in the middle east
they don't do it in other companies they
don't have the balls to do that they'll
come after an attack where it's safe uk
america where
we're all at the table and we have
differences but we're all at the table
and they never ever go after these
companies they always pick out like
those guys because they just
they support it they just don't want to
wear it that's like me coming in here
every day in february going hey all
right tell me something great about my
blackness where is it at yeah yeah yeah
cause guy you em i'm still waiting for
my tribute for the 28 days of black
history month yeah
i assume that because we get along and
we talk all the time you didn't have to
acknowledge my blackness every day after
a while i'll be honest i get annoyed
yeah that's that's what i'm saying i
mean it'd be different if they were like
i'm not playing in the game because i
don't support this and they're wrong and
they did something like that then no
absolutely not but that's not what
they're doing that's true and so the
thing that molly that gets me is the
idea that this was quote optional but
you could see the fallout if you don't
do it is anything really optional in
this in this new climate it's actually
one of the main problems with this is
that it isn't really optional there is
the authoritarianism implicit in some of
these things but there's also an issue
here which i think is this horrific
journalism i mean this is this is a
journalist who's supposed to be covering
sports and it's like
the syndrome where people figured out
that they could make a name for
themselves by opining on their absurd
political views rather than covering the
great talent that they see on the field
or come up with interesting stories
there and that's almost as offensive as
anything else they are it is the same
thing that's happening at the washington
post and elsewhere they are hiring
people not for the job that they're
doing but for what they perceive that
person ads on like twitter or uh or
ticking a box and then what you have is
your your actual brand dissolves espn is
not about sports the washington post
isn't about journalism it's about
identity identity identity ticking the
boxes and everybody's terrified of not
ticking the right box and i think i'll
end on that note because i sound almost
smart
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else